[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm Ramsey personality
George camel joined by the one and only
Dr John deloney and this is your show
America we want to help you take the
right Next Step in your life and your
money and your relationships and your
mental health we are here for you give
us a call at
5225 Fran joins us in New York City to
kick us off Fran welcome to the
show hi thank you um when my husband and
I got married we combined everything and
I took care of pretty much everything
Financial paying the bills ordering
things um whatever and the only thing
that he did was he was in charge of the
Investments um and that worked really
well for 50 years and then he passed
away I'm smart enough to know the things
I don't know and I don't know anything
about
investing and I need help how do I find
someone who can help me without ripping
me off
that's a great question and I'm so sorry
for your loss how recently did he
pass um about eight months
ago can I just say as our new friend
Fran the heaviness of this season I know
it's extra extra heavy I'm
sorry thank you I hate it for you so you
guys were married 50 years a 50 years
and eight days wow well what a amazing
uh leg Legacy and journey you guys have
been on together and I'm guessing over
50 years of investing you've got quite
the nest
EG um it's probably just a little shy of
two million awesome do you know what
it's invested in what kinds of accounts
where they're located you know what kind
of paper trail do you have oh oh I have
I have all of the paper trail and and
um we've we've had you know some Ira
some rth some investment accounts a
whole variety of things um when he
worked for New York City and they happen
to have an incredible
401K uh you know plan and the um from
that alone uh I transferred over into my
name um little shy of a million just
from that so you've got access to all
the accounts you know where they are you
know the account numbers all of that is
in your possession yep right it's it's
everything that was only in his name
from work or wherever has been
transferred to me so the good news is
it's already being invested in things
you don't have to go and choose all of
these from scratch is your question more
how do I handle this going forward do I
need to change any of the Investments I
don't know where to get
started okay well I have as I said I
have all different kinds and uh you know
he was he liked to not put his eggs all
in one basket as it were um so we've had
we have a bunch of little Ira accounts
what I want to do is um consolidate
everything um and a lot of the things
that he did invest in in terms of um his
non Ira things his just regular
investment accounts okay are things that
I was not happy with and I know I want
to change all of that cuz he had a
different philosophy season I do and you
know well I think at this stage of the
game you want you want to manage all of
the risks that you can you do want to be
well Diversified we don't want you
investing in single stocks and unproven
Investments sticking to mutual funds and
index funds is going to be your best bet
and so when it comes to how to move
forward I work with a professional it's
the same reason I don't handle you know
the electrician work around the house
I'm not capable and even if I could
watch some DIY videos I'd probably screw
it up and
myself and that's the case for most with
investing right so we yeah uh we call
these people smartvestor Pros through a
smartvestor pro program that we have at
ramsy we can connect you with investing
Pros that can help you take that right
Next Step and give you guidance when it
comes to investing and I've got one Dave
Ramsey has one and the key here is you
want someone with a heart of a teacher
like you said you're scared of getting
ripped off you don't want to walk in
somewhere and you hand up a bunch of
money and they go and it's gone you go
what would you do with this money you've
worked so hard you and your husband to
build this Legacy and Nest EG and I
totally understand that you want to make
sure you uh you're wise with it going
forward well I've spoken to a number of
financial advisors and they all pretty
much say the same thing where
fiduciaries we going to invest uh in you
in Diversified uh products that align to
your risk um you know risk level um um
and surprisingly not one of them has
said just give me your money I'll take
care of it and if we do okay fine if not
oh well um oddly no one has said that to
me well they all like to keep their jobs
and not have the SEC breathing down
their necks so it makes sense but i'
I've got a great blog I'm going to I'm
going to make sure our team sends it to
you and it's called questions to ask a
financial adviser at your first meeting
so make sure when we hang up I'll make
sure our team sends you that link we can
also put it in the show notes for
today's show if uh all of you listeners
out there want to check that out but
it's really it's asking about their
investing philosophy asking them how
they're going to get paid uh how will
you measure and evaluate performance
those types of questions are the wise
ones to ask in just vibing them out do I
want to work with this person is this
someone I trust is this someone that I
get a good vibe with and those are some
great steps to take and you can connect
with a smartvest pro at Ramsey
solutions.com get started here's the the
one thing I think the reason I use a
Smart Vestor Pro um besides the fact
that they've been vetted is it's an
orientation to a
problem most of the time when I call a
plumber I'm asking a plumber to tell me
what's wrong and how much it's going to
cost them to fix
it when you go see a financial advisor
out of a book what you're doing is
you're saying I want to invest and
they're going to say well what are your
goals like a personal trainer and you're
going to say I want $5 million or in
your case I want to make sure I'm
comfortable and have and able to pay my
bills for the rest of my life great when
you sit down with a smartvestor pro they
are a teacher
first you won't leave that room not
knowing exactly what you're doing and
why you're doing it and how it all
works and that is different than just oh
you just trust me we'll put it in here
and we'll take care of it for you oh
didn't work or it's different it is I am
going to co-pilot this thing with you I
am an expert but I am also a teacher
here's what funny about smart Vestor
Pros I'm I've I have a 20 year NOP 30y
year friendship with my smart Vestor Pro
we were friends before he ever got into
this business and before I ever started
letting him keep my
money after I hired him I said uh he
said hey I'm going to walk you through
how this works and I go I honestly don't
care I trust you like just make it work
and he said that's not what I do what I
do is I will teach you so either we
don't work together I was like are you
kidding me dude like you're my friend
for 30 years he goes either I teach you
how this works or we don't work work
together and I was like all right teach
me how this works and so that's their
orientation and I really appreciate that
you're going to walk into that office
not knowing up from down you're going to
walk out an expert in your own situation
which I think is awesome that's a great
reminder you call the shots here they
don't choose it for you they recommend
and then you get to decide and it's all
on you so if someone's making they're
saying hey just trust me I'm going to do
it no you got to figure out exactly what
they're doing why and you call the shot
thank you so much for the call Fr so
sorry for your will connect you with
that blog
[Music]
article hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus A5 ,000 seller guarantee gives your
offer the best chance of being accepted
the home buyer Edge from Churchill gives
you an advantage over those other guys
go to Churchill mortgage.com today to
learn
[Music]
more
this is the ramsy show I'm George camel
joined by Dr John deloney if you want to
talk about your life your money your
relationships your emotional well-being
your mental health we are here for you
this hour the number to call is
5225 Rachel is up next in Ohio Rachel
welcome to the
show hi thank you for having me
absolutely how can we help today
so I am currently a stay-at-home mom I
am looking to get back into the
workforce however right out of high
school I went right into the air force
because I didn't know what I wanted to
do wasn't able to get my GI bill because
I got injured so I've been kind of going
from job to job to job trying to figure
out what I want to do um the job that I
really liked doing was being a bank
teller so I kind of want to get into
that however I know that I have to have
a good credit score um cuz do a credit
check in order to get a job so I was
wondering if in that case do you guys
still say to close all your credit cards
and how would you go about that uh
needing a good credit score in order to
get a job great question well number one
I actually talk about this in my new
book Breaking Free from broke and the
whole section on credit scores cuz I've
dug into this because this is a question
we get a lot people like to push back
and go I can't get rid of the credit
cards I got to keep my score because of
jobs they they do a credit check but the
caveat here is what they're looking for
is a mismanagement of money they're
looking for a bad or low score I have
yet to see someone who says hey they did
the credit check and I had no score and
I didn't get the job what they're really
looking for is someone to make sure that
you don't have delinquencies that you're
a person of Integrity when it comes to
money and so I would just talk to them
and say Hey listen you're going to do
the credit check you're welcome to do
that here's what's probably going to
happen it's going to come up as
indeterminable here's why I don't have
any
and that's a principle I live by and I
would love to work here and I think I'd
be a great fit and I'm a person of
integrity and character who just lives a
debt-free
lifestyle have you tried
that I haven't tried that no but that
sounds that sounds like a good Solution
that's my guess now someone could prove
me wrong out there where they go nope I
didn't have a credit score and they said
we can't give you the job because it's
some sort of bureaucracy stupid policy
but in most cases what I found is the
credit check just exist to see if you
have a terrible score which you
don't now I am currently on baby step
two so we are paying off uh the credit
cards which we'll have the credit cards
completely paid off by the end of
January and then head to the car oh so
you already have a credit score the
student L yeah so this is not even a
problem this is a
hypothetical yeah it's just a bad credit
score and I've had issues
with I've lost a job opportunity because
it was bad in the past but we are
working towards eliminating that
completely through the baby steps great
well here's what will happen as you pay
off your debt the score is going to get
better and then it will
disappear after about 6 to 12 months
with no open accounts we're talking no
credit card accounts open nothing the
credit score will become
indeterminable okay so you can also pull
your credit report for free at
annualcreditreport.com and that will
show you all of the accounts you have
open out there cuz there maybe one you
forgot about you like oh gosh I didn't
realize that was still open I got to go
close that but yeah this is a you're
going to be okay and uh again to your
point the low credit score can hurt you
the no score I found is not an issue
whether you're renting an apartment cars
you name it they're looking for bad
money
management okay perfect thank you so
much yeah I hope that helps Rachel thank
you so much let's move on to Landon in
Jackson Tennessee what is going on with
you Landon how can we help
today hey what's up guys I appre yall
taking my call sure how can John and I
help so my wife and I are 26 and we are
wanting to start doing small small small
flips um and I'm just you know basically
in my small town you can get a small
property for about 50 to 100,000 bucks
and flip it for
250 um and so we're wanting to start
doing small flips like that but it
honestly just kind of terrifies me but
basically what I'm asking is what what I
guess what does my net worth need to be
at in order to be safe in doing that and
also it you know makes
sense so you want to get into house
flipping because you could 5x your money
very easily in this
town well I mean not necessarily because
I want to 5x my money I I love real
estate I'm a realtor is what I you know
do as a career and it's just you know
something that I grew up watching my
parents do and I'm not a I'm not a fan
at all of the the current Tik Tok trend
of finding refinance buy it over and
over and over and so do you have the
money to do these flips and cash all be
cash debt free okay how much do you have
right now my belt as far as my portfolio
goes so how much do you have in
cash uh in liquid cash about 300 Grand
awesome way to go what are you making
from being a realtor every
year uh this year I did about 450 in
commissions oh my goodness you're
crushing it dude and this is in Jackson
you're talking this is small town estate
45 minutes outside of Jackson it's a
small town outside of Jackson that's
impr going to Jackson yeah I think I
think you make sure you're investing in
your in your retirement and you're
holding off the appropriate um taxes if
you are 1099 doing this yeah um or if
you're under a broker they'll send you
WT you be fine but I all that yeah dude
buy a house $50,000 and pay for the
Renta in cash it's going to be 3x as
more as expensive as you think it's
going to be probably take three times as
long yeah and just as long as you and
your wife have a good plan to stay
married after after the ren then yeah
knock it out I mean I don't think
there's a magic number I think the
number is don't get yourself in trouble
and um if you're buying a $50,000
property and you're going to put $50,000
into it and you have that in cash and
you're going to sell it for 250 it
sounds like a great
deal do you have your primary home paid
off I do wow yeah that's amazing what's
what's your net worth
just or about 800 750 to 800 awesome
yeah this if you're doing it with cash
which is rare these days because it's so
countercultural as as to everything
you've seen on Tik Tok you are doing it
the right way with a whole lot less risk
and so the key is paying cash for the
property cash flowing all the
renovations and making sure on the front
end that you're getting a deal that's
where you're making your money is on the
front end uh on top of some on the back
end if you do it the right way but you
know make sure you're doing your due
diligence of what this project is going
to take cuz like John said you get into
this thing and you realize oh my gosh
this is going to be 50 Grand more than I
thought and the contractor dropped out I
got to find a new subcontractor for the
project all of that stuff is going to
add some stress and headache so just be
prepared for that but you told me you
love it you love this stuff so start
small and go from there and learn along
the way for sure for sure okay cool
appreciate you yeah proud of you man
John that was not how I thought that
call was gonna go see usually judger I I
I had some Prejudice and here's why most
of the people that are younger that call
into the show are broke up to their
eyeballs and they saw the Tik Tok of the
guy who's like dude you don't even need
your own money to get into real estate
investing and buy my course and I'll
show you how and all of a sudden they
call the show and go hey I'm out $2,000
for this course and I made a terrible
financial decision on this property or
they watch HTV and they watch uh chip
gains run a saw and you're like I can do
that forgetting that he's like an
artisanal Craftsman and my favorite is
when they're like I'll just do all the
repairs myself exactly that's a
dangerous dangerous scenario to be in so
do not recommend that at all all right
John we got a lot going on in the ramsy
solutions.com store right now and uh one
of those things the $12 sale where you
can get bestselling books Total Money
Makeover baby steps millionaires your
book own your past change your future
just 12 bucks and many of John's
questions for humans conversations cards
are as low as 10 bucks right now and the
Christmas edition is is back these sold
out early last year so don't don't be
angry I told you you're going to miss
out so go check it all out ramsy
solutions.com
store while you're there you're going to
see a whole bunch of new stuff as well
that's really exciting Rachel Cruz
launch launched her first ever
Illustrated Kids book called I'm glad
for what I have our friend Jade warshaw
just dropped her new book it's a quick
read called money's not a math problem
we're so excited about that launch and
of course I'd be remiss to not mention
that I've got a book on pre-sale my very
first book called Breaking Free from
broke is on pre-order right now in the
Ramsey solutions store you can get all
of that at ramsy solutions.com store
I've I've been loving some once someone
sent me a message John they said I
bought 10 Total Money Makeover audio
books cuz they're on sale and I'm going
to gift it to people in the Ramy baby
steps Community to help them on the
journey that's cool I was like that's
the kind of generosity we need around
here I like it's fantastic so get the
gift for everyone in your life and if
you've lived these principles out go pay
it forward ramsy solutions.com
store is the place to go we'll be right
[Applause]
[Music]
back hey guys it's Rachel Cruz it's open
enrollment season so it's a great time
to explore your healthc care options for
next year if you feel tied down by your
budget check out Christian Healthcare
Ministries chm is not health insurance
it's a faith-based health cost sharing
Ministry that has helped members take
care of nearly billion in healthcare
costs chm is an affordable alternative
to insurance that gives you the freedom
and empowers you to live out your values
and you can join at any time so find out
more at ch ministries.org
[Music]
budget welcome back to the Ramy show I'm
George camel joined by Dr John deloney
we want to help you America take the
right next step with your money in your
life so if you've got a question give us
a call at
5225 and John we found that most money
questions usually intersect with some
level of relationships and mental health
and it just gets messy and intertwin
real quick and so as we dig in I love
that you're here to help people really
unpack the other pieces not just the
numbers on paper but how do I deal with
that in-law that's pressuring me to go
on the trip and how do I deal with the
brother that's strange but now wants the
money cuz he feels like he deserves all
of that gets intertwined yeah there's
always a relational aspect or an
emotional health aspect money scary and
especially nowadays when it's so
expensive just to exist right it's just
expensive to exist and you either have
people denying that it's like just don't
eat avocado toast which is in nonsense
and the other side of it is just elect
the right person and all this goes away
and it's like that's nonsense and so
there's an emotional component to all of
this right
so yeah um if you got emotional
relational stuff going on your life give
us a call too 8825
5225 well John let's get to our question
of the day brought to you by neighborly
your hub for Home Services with 19
service Brands Nationwide neighborly
provider network has trusted local
service pros to handle multiple
different services in and around your
home visit neighbor.com Ramsey to find
and schedule service
today just just buzzing through this
question real quick it's Fant fantastic
feels like a common core math equation
it does today's question comes from Alex
in Virginia I'm just going to tell you
up front Alex buy the car just buy the
car all right here's your question would
you recommend buying an electric vehicle
like a Tesla just to take advantage of
tax credits our gross household income
for 2023 will be
$230,000 our tax liability would be
9,000 we will get 2,000 as a CH child
tax credit that leaves us with a $7,000
tax liability this is the only year
where I can take advantage of federal
tax credits of $7500 for E for electric
vehicle purchase I have no other debt
but mortgage $190,000 balance I already
have a decent functioning car I hate the
fact that federal government is taking
taxes from responsible folks like us and
giving it as a credit to people who will
probably go in debt to buy overpriced e
V here's a pro tip Alex get out of other
people's
heads and stop making up stories about
why other people are doing whatever it
is they're doing and as I tell my
seven-year-old daughter you deal with
you if you want a new Tesla you have the
money and you've got cash go buy it
George drives one Rachel Cruz drives one
I will drive one one day I'll buy a
truck for all of us but I'll get one
I've been in both Rachel's and George's
they're awesome and I'm not going to buy
anywhere between 40 and
[Music]
$80,000 depending on the model on top of
the $7500 credit just to show those
people who I made up stories about you
see what I'm saying you're just causing
yourself a bunch of angst if you want a
Tesla get a Tesla you could also donate
money
that you might get back in a return you
could just give it be a person of
generosity or you can sit down with a
tax professional and work some of this
stuff out all I have to say is no I
would not buy it George just for the tax
credit would I recommend someone buying
a car that they want if they can afford
it absolutely well and then the ending
was funny because he he's wanting to
Stick it to the Man to the government
for giving the credits to those who get
the overpriced EVS by buying an
overpriced EV yeah he'll show them
that'll show him and then you're going
to pay sales tax on that vehicle to the
tune of the tax credit that you just got
back which then goes to the government
anyways okay this is make the math math
John it's not mathing but yeah to his
point he makes 230k and he's got no debt
but the mortgage so the parameter around
knowing if the car purchase is wise is
number one are you doing it for the
right reason are you doing it as a flex
or do you just want to enjoy the vehicle
and you're paying for it with cash and
the total amount of all of your vehicles
everything with motors and wheels
doesn't add up to more than half of your
annual income so if all your cars are
going to add up to over 15 15,000 yes
it's a terrible financial decision for
you right now but I don't think that's
going to be the case get the Tesla cuz
you want the Tesla don't do it for the
tax credits don't do it to Stick it to
the Man end of story Tada can we move on
John can we move on tax credits man
they'll they'll get you pick stepping
over dollars to pick up nickels that's
what Americans are great at we'll show
them all right Elena is in San Diego
Elena welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi George hi John can you hear me
okay yes how can we help okay um well
thanks for having me I um I started
paying off that my husband and I we
started Dave Ramsey were on baby step 2
about a year ago um and we're posed with
this question um if we should sell our
house to pay off the rest of our debt
well most of it um so some history and
historical information here um my mom
has a rental property and she she lives
with us her tenants are going to be
leaving in the next 3 to 4 months and
she said why don't we move to my house
and you guys can pay less you just cover
the mortgage and it's significantly less
and then you can either rent your house
or sell it um and so my husband wants to
sell the house because he's done with my
gazelle intensity and I'm wondering if
we should just rent it or if we should
just sell it and get on other side of
his
debt lot of layers to this financial
chasu let's let's break this down no
it's good it's good so there's a
relational component cuz that piece you
just dropped a little bomb right there
of my husband is done with my gazelle
intensity and the other piece of this is
it sounds like it's about to get real
messy moving into Mom's but we don't
actually own it we're just paying her
the mortgage amount we get to keep ours
and now we're landlords but we still
have the debt and so this I don't know
that it's just on paper this is looking
like a rose I would walk carefully
either way but how much debt do you guys
have so we've paid about 140 we still
have about
340 is that non-mortgage
debt that's student loans 340 in student
loans good God who's the
surgeon anesthesiologist give me good
news you're an
attorney but still did you go to private
school Bry so I uh no I sat on interest
with these low
payments so they ballooned it's probably
more than you took
out oh over $100,000 more in interest is
this why your husband's done with this
Pro this
program so we're we we've gotten into
this and it's been a good year but I
mean I I can just keep going but he's
like he's ready to be done with that
what's your household
income so our household income is about
190 200,000 is that with both of you
working that's with both of
us okay so what what are you on track to
pay off your debt by right
now I'm shooting for three years did you
have a big year just because you had a
couple of great cases or is this is this
typical um no I sold
everything you sold your
practice I sold no so I'm in house I
don't have a practice but I sold we sold
our car and we sold a bunch of furniture
we sold just all kinds of things um and
then I do real estate on the
side
okay let's talk about the mortgage what
is your mortgage payment every month
compared to your take-home
pay um mortgage right now is about
2,800 okay and what is your take-home
pay take-home pay a month is about
$1,000 500 okay that's n so the mortgage
is not killing you guys it's about 25%
which is great that's in our parameters
which tells me uh you've got you know n
of course you have huge payments what
are your minimum payments every month
right
now um
so right now based on you know whatever
income driven repayment type that they
have the minimum payment for all of the
student loans is about 700 that's the
problem
I would get out of this plan unless you
guys are shoveling so much on top of it
that you're actually solving the
interest problem and so I wouldn't sell
the house quite yet I don't know that i'
move in with Mom and do all these
Maneuvers in 3 years you'll be debt free
and you can make different decisions and
do it at a place of Peace instead of
fear so that would be my goal for you
yeah if you think he's frustrated with
the baby steps move in with his mom and
pay her mortgage o they're going to set
your marriage on fire don't do that
thanks for the call Elena this is the
ram
[Music]
show if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything costs too much
or takes too long but something as
simple as custom window covering
from blinds.com can completely change
your space and add value to your home
we've recommended blinds.com for over a
decade so you know you can trust them
from blinds drapes and shutters to
motorized Shades they make it easy and
affordable to upgrade your entire home
and their team is ready to help with
everything from design consultation to
measuring and installation plus there
are never any misleading quotes or
hidden fees everything's backed by their
100% satisfaction guarantee and shipping
is always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40% off everything sitewide
go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George camel
joined by Doctor John deloney it's your
show America so give us a call at
225 lla joins us down the road in
Nashville Tennessee up next lla what's
going
on hey George hey John happy holidays
thank you so much for taking my call how
are you
guys oh my gosh okay so I'm 20 I
recently discovered your show through a
repost on Tik Tok and I was immediately
hooked boom I took the assessment on
yeah I took the assessment on the Ramsey
website and found out that I'm on step
four but my boyfriend and I are living
paycheck to paycheck and just making
things work by the grace of God um to
cut a long story short I uh graduated
high school with an associates degree
debt-free and I'm a dependent of a
veteran so I receive benefits uh and I
came to live in Nashville to go to
school here enrolled at Belmont but with
only three semesters left um this
calculation by the veterans association
suspended my benefits and I was forced
to take a leave of absence from the
school so and that was paying for my
housing so now I'm working full-time
making just under 16 ,000 a year to
cover my basic needs and I'm
transferring to MTSU for instate tuition
and I'm planning on scholarships and the
pel Grant and paying the rest out of
pocket to avoid student loans I also
have no credit history and no idea how
or when I should start to do that I'm
worried about weaing the economic storm
that the housing market is facing and I
just need some trustworthy advice on how
I can set myself up for some success
given my circumstances and our pets
heads are falling off it feels like it's
all coming down lla you do are you doing
okay
you're a neighbor yeah I'm just feel a
lot I was actually thinking about coming
down but I thought you know maybe I'll
give it a call and first try all right
so I'm gonna give you some very very
very specific um uh advice but George is
gonna talk to you more a broader picture
and the only reason I can give this to
you is because I've been on the inside
okay when I was a Dena students at
Belmont in particular they had a program
and I don't know if it's still there
where they took care of the other part
of a veteran's whatever a veteran needed
they took care of
it right yeah I had that but the VA
miscalculated my benefits and said
instead of the two years that I was
supposed to be allotted they said that I
had only I only had six months left and
that I don't have any benefits left have
you applied for a recalculation have
that yellow ribbon yeah I did but the
process just takes so long and um Gwen
from VA the VA office at Belmont said
that I should just just kind of give up
really yeah I've never heard that before
I trust the person I don't know who's
running it now but I trust that person
I've just never heard that yeah oh no
she's wicked smart she knows what she's
talking about that's why I was like damn
this sucks yeah that does suck because
it's one of the best programs I've ever
seen in the United States that they have
at Belmont where they really take care
grateful yeah I was so grateful that I
was able to come and have a whole year
at Belmont and the only reason I chose
to come to Belmont was because I was so
lucky that they have that yellow ribbon
program Asing but once my benefits were
suspended there was just nothing I could
really do about it other than you know
find a cheaper education all right so
we're gonna pick we're gonna I'm I'm
gonna pass it over to George I'm gonna
tell you two things one um I
respectfully would challenge you to not
give
up um I also will respectfully challenge
you to take a
breath you're going to be all right if
you're making and I'm going to say
something that's going to offend people
if you're making $166,000 in Nashville
Tennessee you're making a choice to make
$116,000 I took my daughter to breakfast
the other day and at the McDonald's it
was starting at $20 an hour so if you
make 16 Grand you woke up today and
decided I'm only going to make 16 Grand
and unfortunately for you I see the
signs and I talk to people because this
is my town too and this applies to
everybody you might have to get
uncomfortable you might have to get a
couple of jobs for a six months while
you figure out this VA stuff and the VA
doesn't have a great track record of
always just dotting all their eyes and
crossing their te's but I would not just
bail on a worldclass education that
they're going to take care of you the
way Belmont takes care of their veterans
and
um just sit sit in my house and be like
ah it's all coming down it's not it's a
mess but it's not all coming
down right so one of the problems you're
having right now it's an income problem
it doesn't sound like you have
extravagant bills living a super
luxurious life you don't have a bunch of
debt payments you told me you're debt
free we're beans and rice and you have
an emergency fund in place
already yeah and I've got I've got six
months worth more than six months worth
of savings wonderful Dude you got you
got Che you have a I'll never go into
debt again fund is what that is that's
debt insurance cuz you're not going to
have the car repair that tanks you fear
instilled in me as a child to never go
into dead good well that's good at least
that's a good kind of fear uh but there
is a sort of scarcity mindset right now
of I don't know how we're going to pay
next month's bills you're going to be
okay we need to path out with long-term
you know income increasing uh let's talk
about this boyfriend situation are you
guys like splitting the bills how is
this
working yeah so we live together in a
two bed two bath with uh or two bed two
and a half bath with a roommate um and
we split it three ways 800
each okay and you don't have any
finances com fine
right no okay good let's keep it
separate um we need to increase your
income cuz right now do you know your
monthly expenses off the top of your
head what it takes to run your yeah your
life yeah so I pay $900 in rent and
utilities and then I've been honestly
scraping by with a little bit less than
$100 a week and I'm not putting any
money into my savings except I have this
app called Albert that makes like a few
dollars out of what are you doinga those
apps exist to take your money not make
you money I know they these micro
investing apps we'll take your spare
change and make you a millionaire It In
The Year 3,000 you're gonna have a
million dollars in that account I'm I'm
ditching that you need to be investing
15% of a solid income into a solid
retirement plan that's going to be your
path to Building Wealth and getting out
of the cycle so your A1 right now is to
get a job that pays 15 bucks an hour
bucks an hour 25 bucks an hour that
would change your world wouldn't it to
double your income right now I work as a
right now I work as a stage hand for AI
and when work is good it's good but it's
the holidays you need stable work a lot
of it yeah so I'm I'll get a retail job
before doing seasonal work where there
might be work there might not be and so
Hospitality always bumping they're
always looking for solid people you
sound like a rock star so I have full
faith that you're going to find a great
job make great money doing yeah but but
lla tell me if I'm wrong George she
sounds like a rock star that is trying
to play all the instruments on stage at
the same time those you don't like
oneman bands are rarely good yeah
they're always yeah the oneman bands are
just a little bit like like like a
little
bit like like what are you doing over
there right so hey um are you gonna
marry this
guy yes
when when well the thing is he's a VA
dependent and he is going to completely
for free because both of his parents are
um are this the longest answer for a
date I've ever heard sorry what's the
date okay if he loses his dependency
status then if we get married he loses
his education benefits so after he gets
a degree and what were you studying that
sounds romantic so lovely um I'm
studying I oh my God don't make fun of
me I'm studying music business and
minoring in tourism Hospitality I don't
think that's bad no it's fine I'm not
mocking you at all man do you have a
career goal like what do you want to do
not what degree are you I want to I have
a very clear dream I want to bring
sustainability to music festivals and
stop wasting so much for events and I
want to have a green just music festival
okay that sounds fantastic that's a very
clear goal so uh I would also in the
meantime start to get connected with
people who work on music mus festivals
there's a lot of that going on in this
town and I go get a job at the Ryman and
at Brooklyn Bowl and work all day making
money and then work all into the night
um working in the music industry around
artists and sound guys and Dorman and
all those people seven days a week tell
your boyfriend you'll see them after you
graduate when you'll get married right
but get a but just get after like I only
make 16,000 you're a nationville
freaking Tennessee one of the hottest
economies on planet Earth don't choose
to make 16 Grand and don't give up on
this VA stuff call them and call them
and call them I just wouldn't walk away
from Belmont right now keep fighting lla
I'm gonna send you two great resources
one is our friend Ken Coleman's book The
Proximity principal the other is Dr John
delon's newest book building a
non-anxious life I think both of those
will be of service to you in the season
that you find yourself in so hang on the
line our friend IU is going to pick up
she's going to make sure that we send
you those two books that puts this hour
of the Ramsey Show in the books we'll be
back before you know
it
[Music]
oh
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George Campell joined
by my good friend Dr John deloney and we
are here for you to give you some advice
some wisdom whatever we can do remember
it's free but we are here to help you
win in all areas of your life the number
to call is8 825
5225 Cassandra kicks us off in Tucson
Arizona Cassandra what's going on Hi how
are you we're doing well how can we
help so um my husband and I we um
started a rental car business through
tarot not sure if you're familiar with
that or not I'm very
familiar yes I can almost guess where
this is all
going yeah so we financed um three
vehicles that are now completely
underwater and um in two some it's
become pretty saturated so we're not
doing as well as we had started off
doing because we started off doing
really great now since probably January
it started to kind of taper off and then
the cars got into some ents and then
there was no income from this business
so now we're personally backing it when
we have like no money to back it and so
now it's racking up credit cards and my
husband's um second job that he has is
um having to Fork out the money to pay
for things when in reality that money
should be going towards the credit cards
because he's um when he contracts
workout he has to put on a card and then
gets reimbursed so now we're not being
able to reimburse what he put on the
card because now we have to pay car
payments and
insurance I before before George um digs
into the math here I just need to ask
you before we start talking are you
willing to change your entire posture on
this
deal I want out okay is that what you
mean well I want out I know you want out
but the way you're talking about it is
all of these things are happening to
you everything was perfect and then all
these things happened to us and what
both George and I and any of my
colleagues here would say is when you
leverage your soul when you leverage a
business that you can't cover you are at
the whims of the cosmos as to what
happens and so I've never seen somebody
successfully victim their way out out of
a problem like this I've only seen
people say well that was dumb we did
something that looked good on the back
of a napkin at a Mexican food restaurant
a good one by the way in Arizona and it
didn't work and
so we're going to have to both get two
jobs or three jobs CU we have three cars
that we can't afford we have five cars
actually and we're going to have to
figure this out and we will never ever
ever ever do this again
I've never seen somebody just be like
well then this happened and this should
be going to this and this it the only
way out is you have to change your
posture which is we gambled we put it
all on red 17 and it landed on black 29
we lost it and now we got to pick up the
pieces and go from here does that make
do you get what I'm saying no right I
get it I'm only telling you that because
I love you but there's just no way to
slump your shoulders through this yall
are going to have to say we did it and
now it's time to come out swinging the
other way
okay you ready so yeah all right lay it
out for us what is your current income
if we take turo
away without turo it's about
94,000 okay and What's the total debt
load it's about
110,000 how much of that is the
cars
uh uh 29 on one 29,000 on one 38 on
another and um 20 on another
okay and do you know what all of those
are
worth yeah one's worth 19,000 one's
worth 21,000 and one is worth 12 uh yeah
19 20,000 and 12,000 okay do you guys
have any money liquid
cash I have $1,000 in my emergency fund
okay and you guys have car loans on your
own personal vehicles no those are paid
off we we uh did our debt free scream a
few years back and now here we are
again not the debt free
Alum I know I am completely
ashamed well you're going to get out of
this and one day it'll be a funny story
you tell your kids that's right but
right now there's a lot of pain and fear
as to how we're going to get out of this
ditch um y the good news is you guys
have a good income and without turo
which I assume was taking up some time
could you guys pick up more work more
jobs he cannot he's already tapped out
what is he doing he's um an executive
chef and then he's also a contractor for
a company and he travels quite
frequently for that one is that doing
similar Chef Contracting or what it's
different it's a little bit different
it's it's through it's for like he's
working with chefs for that job but so
still in the same field and then what
you what are you doing I'm an
administrative assistant for him at his
executive chef what do you make
me I make about
16,000 I think I'm confused why would
you work for him when you can go make
double or triple that
elsewhere um I have we have three kids
and no help so I need that flexibility
okay so you're staying at home with the
kids while doing this administrative
work for him part time yeah yeah that
makes more sense okay I was worried I
was like you need to find a different
job okay yeah all right so if we can
clear 100 Grand here and we can pay off
you know 50 60 a year living off nothing
this becomes a solvable problem to just
pay this all off the other way to
approach it is can we find the
difference you know go to the credit
union and go hey I need a difference for
this loan so that I can get out from
under this bad underwater car situation
then you have a smaller amount of debt
to pay off okay but you're not keeping
these cars anyways and so I like the
idea of getting out as soon as you can
from these underwater vehicles but the
only real way to do it is to come up
with the difference and you either need
to do that through savings and cash or
you need to go get a small loan from the
credit unions to cover it okay or if he
travels a lot maybe you sell one of your
paid-off cars and he can Uber to and
from the airport and I know your first
thought is well we can't do that but
here's the deal you're going to have to
either just make peace with you're going
to be paying this off for four or five
years or something has to be different
because the math is not going to change
right so somebody at your local church
will watch your kids for a discounted
rate or you get a job at a local daycare
center where they pay you 32 Grand a
year as a assistant administrator and
your kids go for free or none of this is
what you want but this is what is this
is just choosing reality here or um yall
make peace with it or you sell his car
and you pay off the difference between
two of these underwaters and now you're
down to just one of the cars and you see
what I'm saying you begin to knock it
out real quick there is not a path
forward without
discomfort and the question is which
discomfort are you going to choose the
day-to-day discomfort of not doing much
of anything for the next 5 years or a
really uncomfortable right now with the
opportunity to get free in the next 12
to 18 months and then we're going to
save up some money down the road and
never do this again thanks so much for
the call Cassandra sorry you guys are
going through this this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial peace and you don't see
any way out you need y refi they're not
a debt settlement company and they're
not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumpsum payoff option you could qualify
for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the ramsy show I'm
George camel joined by Dr John delone
the number to call if you want to jump
in with your question about money mental
health relationships we are here for you
at
5225 well John uh as I do I got myself
in hot water on the Internet thanks to a
video that are we posted on YouTube
shorts you know and Instagram reels and
Tik Tok and all that and the video was
simple we get a lot of flack about
telling people hey go get a used car
avoid the car payment there's used cars
that aren't $30,000 cuz that's the big
argument is why would I buy used John
when I can just go get a new car for the
same price if not cheaper than a used
car that hurts my brain and so I did a
video and I just pulled up you know the
auto Trader website and went here's a
used car $5,000 in my area it's possible
and uh the I want to play it for the
viewers and for you and get your take on
this do we have that
video so I got a lot of flack on the
ramsy show for telling people that they
should be buying used cars instead of
new cars and they say to me well George
used cars are just as expensive as new
cars and you can't find used cars under
$5
$220,000 and then I just look at
something called facts and data and go
nope here's a car for
$5,000 and uh I looked in my area and
there's a 2008 Honda Accord EXL for
$4,999 now is it the sexiest car known
to man no but it's under 150,000 Mi it's
got leather it's got all the the sunroof
all the features a boy could want and
it's going to get you from A to B
without something called a car
payment there it is John I did not know
it was going to be that controversial it
reminded me of uh there's no jobs in
this town yeah not unless you want to
work 40 hours a week that's what it felt
like oh so the one thing I got roasted
for was saying under 150,000 mil because
it had
149,000 miles John that's a death trap
you're so
brave you're the be grills of car
drivers so brave you're so brave oh so
yeah one guy at least was honest in the
comments and said you are correct this
car will last well over 300,000 miles if
service regularly uh he who laughs last
owns this car so there you go that's
part of it is people are going if the
car has over 100,000 miles I have to
throw it away and get a new one John
it's like the iPhone came out mine's 2
years old it's trash time UPG and with I
I I think there's some some I I'll say
ancient Merit to that I think with the
cars our parents drove there was an
understanding that once it crosses
100,000 miles it's you need to start
looking right I don't think that's the
case anymore I tried to get my Corolla
to not live and it wouldn't not live you
can't kill this my old Tundra that I
drive now back from a couple of
centuries ago won't go it was just going
to drive for eternity right so it comes
down to you said it in there is it the
sexiest car alive no and have we wrapped
our heads around this as an identity
it's mad house well when all of your
friends are driving you know brand new
cars with leases on them and luxury
vehicles and you roll up in the 08
Accord it's not exactly Turning Heads at
least not for the right reasons uh but
you know what it's really nice John is
you don't have a car payment weighing
that car down it just drives differently
when you don't owe $700 a month as a
flex on your friends who honestly you
need better friends if that's if that's
the environment you're in but here's
some stats that I this is all from my
new book Breaking Free from broke John I
did a whole chapter on car loans
unpacking this but I broke down the
actual stats on on this average
transaction price of a new car over 48
Grand used car almost 33 Grand now let
me remind you the average household
income in America is
$71,000 so most people have multiple
cars with multiple loans on them that is
now outweighing their income and then
they're wondering why they're broke
because they're sending $1,200 to Ford
Motor Company every month to the to the
lending office wondering well inflation
John is just a real problem for me and
then they're wondering why they're
anxious and stressed because Ford motor
company owns them with by the way a
depreciating asset a car that's worth
less money every day you drive it oh
yeah and interest rates are at record
highs the average loan terms keep
getting extended out we're almost at 70
months now average payments are now over
700 bucks for new cars and so the and
then here's the crazy stat consumers
with monthly payments of $1,000 or more
is now at an all-time high of over 177%
one out of five people have a monthly
payment on one car of over $11,000 since
insane and the the other thing I got in
the comments John were well good luck
buying that $5,000 car you're going to
need to put 5,000 into it in repairs
tomorrow cuz that thing's going to break
down I'm like you know what your new car
is the moment you drive it off the lot
it's a used car that's going to have
problems cuz you're driving it and you
don't drive like Jeff Gordon so uh the
other piece of the equation that's
interesting is insurance is more
expensive on newer cars who would have
th it it's going to cost more to replace
the car that cost $50,000 versus your
$8,000 car so you're going to save money
on insurance you can afford the repairs
when you cash flow the $5,000 car and
then you don't have a payment to worry
about and uh then you upgrade over time
we're not saying Drive the 2008 you know
Accord with a bumper hanging off for the
next 5 years or 10 years just upgrade as
you have the cash I'll
also I was coming out of my back field
the other day and I was laughing about
something that my son was doing and I
wasn't paying attention and George and
my truck that I love I just raked it
down our fence just all the way down
sounds like a you problem it is very
much a me problem it's not beautiful but
these repairs that everybody talks
about I'm I'm not repairing an old truck
nope right and so if I was a brand new
Lexus you're right I would take it to a
dealer and have them look at it and
repair it and it would be a million
dollars I'm not going to so even that
argument if it's a Honda Twitter the
engine's not falling out right um and in
fact a number of cars now will last um
and you choose to do things differently
with your money when it's your car and I
don't have to get it fixed because
that's just what I have to do um I just
don't get it fixed and so is it
beautiful nope does it get me where I
need to go every time yep right who
cares who cares who cares who cares well
a lot of the decisions we make around
cars are a reflection of who we're
trying to be it's more about the brand
Association than it is about utility and
so that's become a problem because now
we're like well my buddies all have the
truck so I got to outdo them with an
even bigger truck and that truck has a
$1,000 payment on it that you couldn't
afford and people with car loans often
have other types of debt too it's not
just the car loan they've got their
student loans hanging around they've got
the credit card balance that's been
hanging around there's personal loans
medical debt maybe on top of a mortgage
that's too big so all of this just
compounds and adds more stress and as
you've seen from this hour John car cars
are Underwater All Over America right
now what they paid for it is now not
it's not what it's worth and the loan is
still 40K but the car is only worth 25
what do I do you just don't have that
problem when you have have it paid off
you want to get real controversial hit
me um when I got my first job as a high
school
teacher I drove a car that uh didn't
have an air conditioner in Houston
Houston so I had to wear an undershirt
and hang up my dress shirt that I wore
aired out no I just hung it up in the
back seat and when I got there I would
then put it on that way it wouldn't get
wrinkled when I got there here's what
I'm telling you was that ideal no was
awful it was awful but it was mine and I
wasn't willing at the time um to sell my
soul for this this idea I can't do it I
can't that word I the phrase I can't is
not true it's I won't I won't do it
that's fine you want to go into debt and
sell your soul cuz you won't fine but
there are people all over the place
figuring it out figuring it out you can
you can deal with it well if you guys
want to learn more about this I have a
whole chapter in my new book called
Breaking Free from broke on car loans
where I unpack what I call Carmageddon
John which is the disaster and crisis we
find ourselves in I unpack how
depreciation works on these cars I
unpack uh the logic of if you just
invested that car payment you could be
so wealthy it would blow your mind to
where you're going to go I'm never
having a car payment again and then I
also show people how to buy a car the
right way the Tactical steps to go buy a
car with cash with peace with confidence
because nobody wants to get screwed on a
deal and so there's a right way to do it
to do your research to negotiate all the
different ways you can buy a car in
today's world I walk you guys through
that in this book and I hope it helps
people avoid the Trap of car loans and
the myth that I'll always have a car
payment no you won't not if you just get
out of the cycle once and for all by
paying cash for that car and upgrading
over time so if you want to check out
that book it's on pre-sale right now
ramsy solutions.com SL store it's called
Breaking Free from broke this is the
Ramy show we'll be right
[Music]
back
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Dr John deloney
this is your show America so give us a
call at
8825 5225 we'd be happy to attempt to
give you the right Next Step In Your
Money life your relational life your
emotional life we are here for you
shakina joins us up next in Portland
Oregon shakina welcome to the
show hi hey how you doing good how are
you we're doing well how can we help
today
um so I just was wondering if you guys
could help me and my husband we're just
trying to figure out how to stay in our
budget and also save money but also pay
off debt at the same time anything else
you want to
do no that's it that's it just pay off
debt save live spend go on vacation okay
this ay and get a pony it's a common
problem yes okay so tell us about your
your financial state is this the first
time you guys have gotten on the same
page with money your first time
budgeting how new are you to all this um
I started budgeting um probably like two
months after we got married um I got one
of those like budget planners where you
have like the separated money and oh you
went like super nerd on this yeah that's
fun where is he in all this is he like
okay you do that that's fine but I'm
going to do what I want with
money uh no actually he doesn't really
spend money that much wonder you married
well pay the bills yes he's a pretty
awesome guy I love him a lot so is the
problem as the great Taylor Swift asks
you I I honestly don't know well if it's
not him there's only one other
person yeah I
well yeah I don't know so what what do
you think is the problem right now you
said how do I stay within my budget
tells me you're not staying within the
budget you're overspending you're not
living on less than you make yes what do
you attribute that to is it do you have
too many bills is it all the debt
payments what would help you get out of
the cycle I think it might be the debt
payments and also um I'm thinking maybe
either our budget is too high
or um well the budget is not it's not
aspirational the budget is just reality
so what does your take-home pay every
month so my husband brings home 4720
before tax but after tax tax it's about
35 to 3700 a month okay and are you
working outside the
home no I a stay-at home mom how many
kids uh we have one and then we have
another one due in March woo part well
now's the time to get your money right
yeah you got another line item in the
budget
coming okay so we're trying to make this
all work off $3,700 or 3,500
bucks yeah that's
tight yeah live it could be a little
more than that um we actually live in
Woodland Washington okay but he works in
Rainer Oregon and so the Oregon taxes he
has to pay those ouchie so how much debt
do you guys have
total all together it's about
13,629 in debt because we were offered a
house last minute it um and we needed
something bigger because what we were
staying in was getting pretty tight hold
on you had to I'm confused here what was
the second debt um it's $2,000 and it
was towards the deposit first and last
month deposit for our new house that we
just move for you're renting this
house yes what's the
rent uh 1,200 okay so you know it's high
compared to your take home pay it's not
the thing that crushing you guys and it
doesn't sound like a ton of debt
comparatively to your income so if you
were able to throw let's say a th000
bucks a month at this debt it would be
gone in a less than a year right a
little over a thousand bucks yeah yes
are you able to do that right now or do
you need more
margin um so I we're able I we think
that we'll be able to pay off that
$2,000 by the end of January okay that's
what we're trying to do and then we're
just trying to figure out how to put
toward more money toward our cost
debt cuz right now that monthly payment
is
257 okay so it's because we bought a
used car from a dealership so it was a
higher price used car but um my husband
has good credit so we were able to get a
lower finance
payment okay well we're going to work
the debt snowball do you guys have a
th000 bucks in the bank right now no
that's what we're struggling to get
right now okay that needs to be your A1
we're making minimum payments on on the
debts we're not eating out we're not
doing anything except for getting that
th000 bucks and because you guys have a
baby coming I would pause debt payoff
and just stack up as much cash as you
can until baby and you were home
safe okay so I'm actually it's I know
it's sounds weird but I'm telling you to
pause the baby steps for a few months
until we get through this we call it
stor mode uh and we get you and baby
home how much could you save up in the
next four
months I think in the next four months
we could
probably yeah we could probably save
about 3 to 4,000 good so that'll give
you four grand that you'll have in there
and we'll get to the debt as soon as
that's done and you guys are are healthy
and safe we can use the 3,000 of the
4,000 and start attacking that
debt okay but I think your problem right
now is you're trying to do a lot at once
you're pregnant there's a lot of
emotions going on and you guys are
scared cuz you got another baby coming
and life's already tough and the the key
is the budgeting method that you use
makes all the difference so what are you
using right now to
budget so right now we have um a budget
for food uh rent but how are you doing
the budget every every week or every
month on paper we budget uh yeah on I
will I do it in my notes on my phone but
I budget for food gas and um tithes for
our church okay we're going to hook you
up John and I with an app called every
dollar to where you both you and your
husband can log in and see this have
visibility and I'm even going to give
you the premium version for a year so
that the transactions come through
automatically connecting to your bank
there's a paycheck planning tool so that
you know you've got all the bills
covered before the month is over if
you're willing to use it I'll give it to
you yes we will definitely use it
awesome I also think um your what does
your husband do for a
living He is a CNC
journeyman uh machinist okay
um man that sounds like a pretty
compressed salary for that level of
skill yeah he's looking he actually me
and him just talked last night and he's
wanting to look into going into
engineering um would that require more
schooling um he said it would and I told
him it wouldn't be a good idea if he did
because because he already has uh a
degree in college what's the degree in
and he has one in English I believe I
don't remember what his other degree is
and then I have my music degree and
they're both going unused right
now yeah yeah there's not a lot of
English Majors that become engineers um
but also I'll say I went and got another
degree because it was right for me and
my family and it has transformed the
entire deloney family tree okay so just
because you already have a degree
doesn't mean you need to go back and get
education you need you don't need new
education you often need to go get new
education um you just have to be
intelligent about what you're doing and
how you're doing it
okay yeah and that means paying cash not
going into debt and having a goal in
mind of what that career is on the other
side yeah and I told him I don't want I
I think it's funny that you guys are
telling me this because last night I was
telling him like I think we should save
as much as we can first before we try to
pay off our debt because then we'll just
keep going into more debt it's true
but something has to give either he has
to work this job full-time and then go
to a local Walmart and throw boxes until
3: in the
morning to help you guys you can't have
him home all the time you can't have him
not trying to get more education so he
can further his career you can't have
him not doing this and not doing that
and not doing this or you you can't not
go get a job and put your kids in dayare
you can't have all these things we're
not going to drown under this debt and
be so sick to your stomach all the time
because about this money issue so you
either have to make some short-term
sacrifices that'll be brutal and will
cause one or both of you to have very
different
lives so that you can be free on the
back end or you're just going to choose
misery ongoing it's just going to be
tough tough tough tough hang on the line
we're going to give to you every dollar
premium thanks for the call sh thanks
for the call
[Music]
sh
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Dr John deloney
hey if you enjoy this show do us a quick
favor it is free and it won't take you
much time and that is if you like the
show consider hitting the Subscribe
button the follow button leaving a
review sharing it with your friend
texting it to the family group chat and
just let them know hey I've been
enjoying the show thank you guys would
enjoy it as well and uh been loving
seeing the the Spotify rap John Amazon
music has uh named as one one of the top
podcasts of the year and so it's an
honor and uh we don't we don't take it
lightly that you guys decide to spend so
much of your time hanging out with us
and being inspired by the callers and
sometimes avoiding some of the mistakes
they make we so appreciate that all of
the many many thousands of listeners out
there appreciate you guys let's go to
the phones Tina joins us in Jacksonville
Florida what's going
on hey thank you for having me on the
call uh so we were just starting the
program my husband and I and I threw a
very bad series of mistakes with car
trade car trade car trade and now in
serious negative equity and uh my
husband and I talked about it and we are
willing to do whatever it has to take to
you know we're going to sell the car um
we found a dealership that's willing to
buy it but we got to cover the negative
equity so I tried to take out a
signature loan through my credit union
and we were declined so now it's like
what do I do what's my next step do I
try to Devi up amongst credit cards do I
just bite the bullet and pay off this
car do I try and take a home equity loan
where do I where do I go well any option
that involves moving the debt to other
debt I I hate that I have to tell you
this is not going to solve your
problem think about it like this you
have bullet wound in one in your foot
shooting any other part of your body
will not fix that bullet wound in your
foot that you got it so here's the
here's the options you have that don't
involve debt number one is you guys save
up the difference that you owe and then
sell it so you can cover the full amount
that's owed or uh you said you got
declined at that credit union have you
tried others did they tell you the
reason is it due to your credit
score credit score okay so your credit
score is shot because of was there
delinquent payments um no uh
overutilization okay we with our house
and all of our credit were about half a
million in debt oh my goodness how much
Consumer Debt do you guys have
serious I'm sorry how much Consumer Debt
do you have outside of the mortgage um
we have 127 in credit card 127 in credit
cards
yeah 127,000 in credit cards what did
you put on these
cards um stuff for the house helping out
our kids um vacations that we shouldn't
have gone on what's the interest rate on
these U the majority of them you know
they vary between 12 and
18% what what about this situation I'm
I'm asking you this not to beat you up
but I I I really want to know where your
where your psychology
is you're half a million dollars in
debt the fact that you're considering
trying to clean up some of your debt
issues with more
debt like at what point what does it
stop for
you it has to stop right because um we
want to retire in five years and we know
it's not possible Right
if we don't change and so I'm willing to
you know do whatever it takes what's
your household income listen to a couple
of the shows um and you know um Dave had
said take out a personal loan to pass
the equity sell that car get a beater
car you know lower your debt total debt
so that's what I thought we could do but
it doesn't seem like and I don't trust
my own decisions clearly because if I
did I wouldn't be here so what is your
household income
uh monthly we bring we bring in monthly
we bring in about
13,000 okay good and what is your total
minimum payments on all of the debt that
you have the Consumer
Debt total minimum payments is
monthly um I'm got to go grab it um
about
4700 okay are you able to put an extra
th000 2,000 3,000 4,000 on top of that
to pay it
off that's what we were going to do you
know starting with the the smallest
first good um but considering I owe
almost 880,000 on this car we thought we
could get out of you know get rid of it
and that would take a huge chunk out how
much upside down are
you about 22,000 and are you sure of
that because you said the dealership
said they'd buy it for this amount well
the dealership's going to lowball you
comparatively to a private party sale
oh so I haven't tried private party um
the car the balance we owe is about
80,000 and when I go through Kelly Blue
Book um it's between 55 and 60 is the
value and the car dealership is offering
US 58 because it's a a 2023 with really
low miles on
it okay well we want to get as much for
this car as we can to shrink that Gap do
you guys have any money in the
bank just
,000 okay you have anything in your home
you could sell
yeah um we thought about that you know
like I said we're just getting started
and we can start you know like selling
off and start making my list of things
that I could get rid of I'm talking
tools guitars motorcycles you guys sound
like you bought some stuff with those
credit cards jet skis everything no
nothing tangible that's worth anything
more than like household
goods I'm at the point now I'm willing
to sell my wedding set if that would get
us out of debt what is the house
worth the house um is worth if we go by
Zillow because I don't have the comps
but if we go by Zillow it's worth about
424 and what do you owe on the mortgage
273 okay
and what was your total Consumer Debt
load I had cut you off What's the total
of all the Consumer Debt
combined of everything is not including
the house
233 okay this might be the car and
student loans and credit cards this
might be one of those situations where
you make the ultimate sacrifice of
selling the house you'll clear about 150
maybe 130 after fees and that gets you
down to 100,000 in debt but also 20
20,000 of that you sell that car and
that knocks off another 80 off the
total and what happens then is you're
going to have to rent for a while it may
be a long time how old are you at least
you can get out of
this I'm 59 okay it
um when my mom went back to school she
got her tenure Prof her job at the age
of 57 she just retired in her mid
70s at May that not it's not May that's
100% what you're looking at okay you're
going to have to go find a job and yall
just going to have to work and scratch
and Claw consider selling the house even
if it's just let's Sprint and get this
20,000 bucks to get rid of this car
let's just do that let's go ahead and
list at private sale just to see what
happens too I there's something the fact
that a dealership would offer you more
than Kelly Bluebook doesn't doesn't
register with me but I don't know enough
about the car or anything like that it
doesn't sound right but maybe maybe um
and then you and your husband have to
decide are we going to get one two or
three or four jobs do we want this no I
don't see a picture where you all retire
in five years I just don't and so I
think the quicker you can you can grieve
that and say we wanted this to be the
case but it's not going to be let's
shoot for 75 instead of
65 um then you're going to it's going to
give you a little gas in the tank and
y'all just got to knock this thing out F
like item by item by item it will not be
how you drew it up and you have to you
have to commit to taking debt off the
table it can never be an option for you
ever ever
ever agreed I'm so sorry I'm sorry you
got to learn this lesson this way Tina
we're going to send you a Financial
Peace University it sounds like you're
new to Our Gang we're going to send it
to you we're going to send you for a
year the premium version of every dollar
it's going to help you and your husband
get aligned to do something youall have
never done before which is make a budget
and make money decisions together that
puts this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books I'm George camel he's John deloney
want to thank all the folks in the booth
keeping the show afloat and you America
thank you so much for listening we'll be
back before you know
[Music]
it
m live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George Campbell joined
by my good pal Dr John deloney and we
are here to serve you America give us a
call at tri8 825 5225 and we'll talk
about your life and your money Ashley is
going to kick us off in Denver this hour
Ashley welcome to the
show thank you absolutely how can we
help
um this question is mostly about my
daughter and we're trying to figure out
how to help her
um she is 20 years old and she lives in
a different state than us um mostly just
because it's pretty expensive here um
but she's really struggling um we're
talking get up the wo and um we're
having some issues with some
drugs as well as making some poor
choices where we have been in
jail um for short periods of time
and uh we just don't know what to do we
want to help her I mean we she calls me
every week to talk but I know giving her
money financially is not a smart thing
because it won't get used appropriately
is she asking for money on these
calls she's mentioned it and at this
point she stopped asking
um
because we don't have it to give her
we're still working through Ramsay's
baby steps
ourselves and I said honey we just
that's we don't have that kind of money
and two if you really look at your
finances you will find the money it's
just about how you budget what is she
doing right now is she in school is she
working um she was in school for a year
and she dropped out saying it wasn't for
her which is fine not everybody needs a
four-year college degree I I believe
that wholeheartedly um but she's working
on a farm now and she loves it is she
still actively
using yes um unfortunately and I wish I
could give you different news it's it's
any sort of life change or behavior
change is going to or relationship
change will have to come on the back end
of her choosing to not be using
anymore yeah
I know what she was using was legal in
Colorado but it's not really legal
everywhere and she just doesn't want to
give it up okay and I think it's causing
some Behavior Yeah well yeah of course
and so the the only way I've seen people
this be uh people have effective
relationships moving forward is that
y'all meet somehow in person whether she
comes home to visit you for the holidays
or you fly out there you drive out there
and you take her out and I say this all
the time and people kind of roll their
eyes the reason I tell people to take
somebody that they love when they have
to have a difficult conversation to
breakfast is twofold number one it
changes the environment if you have a
conversation in your house the same old
house that you got in trouble at when
you were a kid or what it just changes
the the dynamic and there's a lot of
literature about the psychological shift
when you're in a different environment
that's number one number two if you wait
till dinner you get these Marathon
conversations that don't end till 10:
1100 or 12:00 at night if you start at
breakfast the Sun is up it's 8:00 in the
morning it's 9:00 in the morning it's
10:00 in the morning and we can talk for
a while and it's still Sunshine outside
it still feels like there's some
optimism in Hope okay but I think you
have the conversation and
say me and your dad have decided we can
help in this way or that way that might
be she can come live with you as she
goes to rehab she can um stay with she
she can keep working on this phone and
y'all will support X Y or Z if she wants
to whatever y'all
decide but it only comes on the back of
she goes through some sort of treatment
program or goes to meet with a group and
then she gets to hold all of the
relational cards and so the the way you
phrase it
is we don't work well without you being
whole and well and you get to choose
whether you want to be whole or well and
with us or not it will break our heart
if you choose something else but you get
to do that because you're an adult
and that way she can't say they kicked
me out they don't love me they they I
did this thing and they drew a line no
you chose it and I'm I'm so heartbroken
it we'll be right here when you get back
we love you love you love you love
you yeah that's the only way I've ever
seen that be successful and then you and
your husband have to grieve and weep
bitterly because one of the people you
love more than anything on planet Earth
is an adult and adults have access
to poor decisions and it's heartbreaking
to see adults that we love making
decisions that we know are destroying
their
lives yeah I know it looks like she may
be going back to jail and we've talked
about this like she'll lose everything
yeah um we've talked about going out
there and getting a storage unit and
helping her pack it up just
because we're like What do we do like we
can't not like we don't have control
over that part but talking with her and
just saying we will pay for a storage
unit for this many months but after
that it sounds like you are more you're
more stressed about this than she is
what has the conversations been like on
her side because it doesn't sound like
she really wants to change her life at
this
point anytime she's gotten into trouble
she'll call me really upset um what is
trouble
me financially with the cops
with the cops financially um after she
got out of jail she called me and said I
don't know what to do like
and
um and and contrary to popular belief or
what your friends might tell you saying
the said telling her if you're sober
come home right now I'll come get you
I'll get you a flight you can't bring
drugs into my house and you can't come
into my house if you're not of sound
body and mind
but if you're sober come home that's
okay that I don't think that's enabling
I think that's love and that's
connection okay it's connection with
boundaries connection with
accountability and then she gets to make
a
choice yeah I know she decided to leave
at one point because we said we weren't
going to allow the drugs in our house
and I didn't care if they were legal or
illegal in this state that it wasn't
happening and so she made a hard
difficult choice
she did and it's she's it's not gotten
better it's gotten worse yeah um
everything has um and it breaks my heart
as a parent myself you can't change
another
adult no and it feels powerless
huh it does feel powerless and I mean
we've talked about trying to help her
get out of debt by saying you can live
here for free meals are free obviously
like room and board this is not a
this is not a dead issue you're trying
to find a thing that you can fix for
her but none of this stuff improves
until she's
sober yeah and right now I don't think
she's want to be she I've told her that
she and she's tried to negotiate
different things with us so she can come
home and I'm like and it always just
feels
wrong and as a parent she won't
understand this cuz she's on on the
other side of it but as a parent the IDE
idea that I'd have to tell my kid no you
can't come home unless dot dot dot
they'll never know how hard that is I
think you're doing the right thing so
sorry going through this ash for you
we're going to send you a copy of Dr
John delon's own your past change your
future so you can heal and grieve and
navigate this wild Journey that you're
on so sorry you're going through
[Music]
it
welcome back to the ramsy show I'm
George camel joined by Dr John deloney
John we got a lot going on around here
and one of those things is uh the
pre-sale for my new book Breaking Free
from broke did you see the actual uh
this is the real one John we got it the
other day it feels just right is
everything you hoped and dreamed for
with well number one it's got you on the
cover that's really all I care that's
what America needs right now um usually
need healing John they only put my face
on it so you got your whole bdy on here
which is impressive I'm not going to lie
the further you zoom out from my face
the better it looks so I want it as
small as it could be on the cover I
agree the team did a great job with it
it's uh Breaking Free from broke the
Ultimate Guide to more money and less
stress and this is my story 10 years
here at Ramsay 10 years going from broke
with 40,000 in debt to Baby Steps
millionaire unpacking all the traps if
you've listened to Borrowed future or
the fine print the podcast that I hosted
it has that kind of investigative feel
with tons of research with tons of humor
and by the end you're going to have the
ick you're going to want to shower and
you're going to want to break free from
the toxic Matrix that we've all found
ourselves in as you listen to the the
calls on the show you know exactly what
I'm talking about we are stuck in this
cycle of debt because we have fallen for
a system designed to keep us broke and I
will show you a clear path to break free
and uh have more margin more options
more joy than ever before and it's on
sale right now for 20 bucks at ramsy
solutions.com store and we'll throw in
100 bucks in free bonus items like the
ebook audiobook a free talk on video an
exclusive online event and so much more
so I appreciate everyone who's checked
it out so far John when does it uh H the
streets hits the streets January 16th
very is the pub date and so pre-order
before then and you'll get all of those
goodies this is the book I wish I had
that you know everything you wish you
knew about money this is money 201301
101 and it's conversational cuz I don't
know how to write so I wrote like a
fifth grader joh it's very easy to read
and conversational all right let's get
to the calls Cameron joins us in my
hometown Boston Massachusetts what's
going on Cameron ceron hey guys thanks
for taking my call thank you for having
the accent I was hoping you would have
just going to say that oh god um I just
wanted to start off by saying thank you
for motivating me um as of now I'm
through baby step one and as of
yesterday I have paid off five out of
$6,000 of my credit card debt way to go
man how does it
feel yeah it feels great what credit
card is
it what's that what what credit card is
it
uh it was uh Capital One oh man are you
g to miss it
yeah nope because I cut it up amen man
I'm proud of you how can we help today
you're gonna have to use cash at your
hav boss do did I do it right John just
offended all people groups right there
somehow I love that love that um so the
reason for my call today guys is um I'm
26 and I'm still I'm living at home I
moved back into help me out with
finances and stuff um I still have a
good bit of debt and I have a savings
account which um would help me pay off
my truck a little bit but I'm also
keeping it around because it's basically
like six months of an emergency
fund um so basically where I'm at today
is I don't I don't know if I want to
sacrifice that to dig into my truck or
keep it around for a house because I'm
obviously really trying to save up for a
house and I don't want to see that money
just just go but but you're seeing that
money just go every month you when you
make a payment on a depreciating
asset I
understand just whether you want it to
go today or later but it's
going okay man this yeah I'm going to
give you some hard news and that is
Cameron's plan has not been working and
it will not work in the foreseeable
future if you continue to carry this
debt use this money to buy a house which
then depletes the emergency fund while
you still have debt you got to do things
in a certain order with Focus intensity
and that's the ramsy baby steps and it's
the same one I followed to get out of
$40,000 in debt in 18 months and buy a
house the right way with peace and
you're going to get there it may take
you know a few years longer than you
wanted it to but right now that money is
spoken for cuz it's got you know Ford
Motor Company's name on it cuz you owe
on this truck so how much do you have in
savings so after paying the credit cards
off I have about $10,000 left in my
emergency fund okay and six months of
expenses is around $8,000 so I have the
$1,000 emergency fund and then I have
that other savings account with 10,000
in it so you got 11k to your name and
what's left on your debt you got th000
bucks on credit card what
else um I owe 32,000 on the truck what
do you make why how much money do you
make um this year I'm going to bring
home about
65 dude that is a lot lot of truck for a
guy with your
income it is a lot of truck do you need
the truck you use trck
for so I got into the electrical union
so it was a little bit of an Impulse buy
I'm not going to lie can it be a impulse
sell like this
weekend I I I know it it would be tough
to part ways with but I guess I could
sacrif are there not more trucks out
there there are definitely more trucks
out there so could you downgrade and
truck and and do it with
cash I I could I could what if what what
would that truck sell for if you did you
know got the most you could for it so
the dealer would probably lowball me at
like 26 but I could put it up on
Facebook and probably get 30 okay and
you have the money aside could you get a
cheap truck right now to beat around in
and then upgrade
later yes this gets you out of debt
completely right or do you have more
debt no that's it just the on the truck
bro you're free I would be free tomorrow
instead of trying to arduously pay this
thing
off cuz it's going to take you a while
to pay off
$32,000 and it's just going to continue
to be worth less and less and less and
less which is also going to delay you
from buying a house which you told us is
your dream yeah absolutely so do you
want a house or do you want a sweet
truck that's going down in value every
day I really would like a house and if
you meet somebody and she goes outside
and sees this
truck you're like yeah that's right this
is my truck and right now you have to
take her to your mom's house not that
cool so what if yeah you just bit the
bullet sold the truck you're debt-free
worked really hard to get your own
place by the age of 30 you're total I
mean your life is so transformed you
would even recognize
it yeah that would be that would be nice
um so if I sell the truck and still you
know if I only get 30,000 for it it it's
obviously okay to dip into the savings
and cover the difference yeah you're
free manover the difference that leaves
you with 8K and you need a you need a
car still so you're going to get
something that'll get you around for
maybe you know 7K leaving you with a
th000 bucks but now look at where you're
at you got no debt you have all your
income to your name and now we can
restock this emergency fund up to 6
months then we can start working on that
homeown payment and we'll get another 30
40 50k over time and when you don't have
debt weighing you down you're going to
get there faster you get to be your own
bank
dude yeah that sounds great to me are
you a good
electrician that wasn't rhetorical are
electrician um no I'm an apprentice so
I'm but someone's paying you $65,000 a
year to do
this yeah yeah I'm still uh I'm still
working my way but I'm getting better
and better every day I'm learning dude
that's pretty good to be terrible I talk
to you today you're awesome ads I'm not
good at my job but I get paid
$65,000 people ask me are you good at
the radio I go no not great not great no
I I am I am good at my job I just don't
know everything obviously every day I
learn stuff so it's good to that's good
well I say that to say this nobody's
hiring you because of your truck they're
hiring Cameron because they trust him to
do the electrical work needed to be done
absolutely and so the truck is for
Cameron to feel good about himself and I
want you to feel good about yourself
aside from a thing that you
own yeah are you dating anybody
Cameron I am I've been with my
girlfriend for six years and we're
mutually um working hard to you know
save up for this house okay I want to
challenge you okay will you do a 90-day
challenge sure you can have a couple
days off for Christmas here's my 90-day
challenge you get done with your
Apprentice work and you're
exhausted you high five your mom you
give your girlfriend a
shout and then you go deliver pizzas in
that cold winter or you go bartend or
you go work security you go do something
for 90 days on top of your apprentice
job and in 3 months you're going to be
so tired you can't see straight and you
will have completely transformed your
financial life in unfathomable
fathomable ways people underestimate how
much they can radically change your life
in 3 months go for it game on
[Music]
go
I'm George camell joined by Dr John
deloney this is the Ramsey show it's a
free call at AAA 825
5225 it is that time of the year folks
in a few weeks we are going to be doing
a special giving edition of the ramsy
show and we want to hear stories from
you about how you have given gener
generously this season maybe you tipped
that waitress $100 you bought
Thanksgiving dinner for a family who
couldn't afford it maybe you blessed
someone in Need by giving them a car or
maybe you've been on the receiving end
of generosity and had your life change
by it we want to hear from you we want
to hear your stories we want to inspire
others with it so here's what you need
to do go to Ramsey solutions.com
askk and put giving in the subject line
and our team will be reaching out and
sourcing some of the best stories and
sharing them on the show we do this
every year at Christmas it's one of our
most popular shows and it's happening on
December 18th I'll be on with our good
friend Dave Ramsey and we'll be sharing
those stories so start sending them in
today and let's celebrate living like no
one else so you can give like no one
else ramsy solutions.com
askk Iris joins us in North Dakota Iris
welcome to the
show hi thank you for taking my call
absolutely how can John and I
help um okay so recently I had search on
YouTube on how to get out of debt cuz
I'm a little bit deep in um one of the
major ones is I owe to the IRS and um I
was just wondering if it was smart or
not to dip into my 401k to pay for
that do you have any other
debt yes um credit card personal loans
and um my
car okay well I'll answer your question
and we'll do that's the short answer and
the answer is no do not pull from your
401k to pay off the IRS how much do you
owe
them um 10 grand a little bit under 10
grand Okay and like nine something have
you been in contact with them are you on
some kind of payment plan where does it
stand um recently I logged back into my
IRS account and I started making
payments um as soon as I get like some
cash I would just put it in there and
try to pay it off um but I read through
some information that that would be like
the first one to pay off um correct
aside of my other debt yeah so you want
to make minimum payments on all of your
debts but the IRS debt goes to the top
of what we call the debt snowball so we
usually say hey list all your debts
smallest to largest attack the little
one with a Vengeance once you knock that
one out move on to the next smallest
debt but IRS debt is different because
the IRS can royally screw up your life
and they can garnish your wages and so
we put that at the very top of the list
that is your A1 is to get rid of this
debt you do nothing else you don't save
you don't invest you don't buy things
you pay off the IRS so how quickly could
you do that if you got really intense
and just focused on that well that's
been my plan because I recently found
you guys and I did started to do the
snowball the baby steps um I did I just
recently did a baby step number one and
I saved $1,000 and in the meantime I
have been paying little by little CU I
have two jobs like I work Non-Stop and
um I get cash tips so any cash that I
get I deposit it and then pay the IRS
um so what's your in last year um well
it depends cuz you know as a server it
it varies um but last year I made
70,000 I did serving I work in school
and um I do like ride share on the
weekends too so if you went all out you
were working non-stop all of these jobs
how quickly could you pay off the 10K
while making minimum payments and just
covering your basic bills food shelter
utility Transportation could you do this
in four months five months I I believe I
can my friends think that I'm going
crazy because I've been reading like the
ramsy um books and Rachel Cruz and I've
been I put a lot of stuff on sale and
people are questioning my
sanity I'm fine I'm just trying to like
come up with the money and get out of
this hole that I'm in um before I can
you know continue with my savings and
paying everything off hey Iris you know
who's
Crazy your broke
friends oh my God your friends are broke
I my friends buy some of my stuff and
she's like are you okay like like your
house like you worked so hard for it I'm
like but you don't understand my
situation because everything that I have
most of it is on credit cards yes dude
I've learned welcome to the gang Iris
okay or the cult as some call us
welcome this is a great you know what
you are you're free you're heading
straight to
Freedom yes that's how I feel I feel I
feel so calm but at the same time I just
feel like I need to keep going and going
and going going um so so do not dip into
my 401k can I give you a great quote
that will inspire you Iris yeah of
course it's the first quote of my new
book Breaking Free from broke this is
how it opens it's a CS Lewis quote when
the whole world is running toward a
cliff he who is running in the opposite
direction appears to have lost his
mind that's you you're going against the
grain you're going against what culture
is doing against what your broke friends
are doing and it looks like you've lost
your mind
but instead you running away from the
cliff instead of towards it so we are so
proud of you you're doing all the right
things but we've got to aggressively get
this IRS debt out of off our back what's
the rest of your debt What's the
total the total um 48 663 and that
includes my car payment or my car and a
personal loan what's the car worth and
what do you owe on it I owe 13 on it and
um I think I bought it for
23 okay well we'll keep the car I was
seeing if that was the the ankle biter
we could get rid of but it's not that
much of your world I would just
aggressively pay it off in the debt
snowball and I think you're going to be
at of debt I mean you got a total of 10K
plus the 48 you got 58k in debt you make
70 uh that's how much I made last year
and this year I haven't done much of the
right share but I've been picking up um
on the weekends cuz that's when it it's
the busiest what do you want to do what
do you want to do long
term um I'm not sure yet um I had future
plans because I had planned on getting
my husband here from another country and
I did but things didn't work out so that
let me that left me in a little bit of
debt and I counted on his where is he
like on his income um he's here now but
I'm not counting on his support
financially and
that's one thing that I had in mind but
U cuz he was going to help me pay off
like what like one of the personals was
that I I took it aone to get him here
and now he is here but we're separated
now so now I'm left with that and um and
I just need to get out of this by
myself sorry to hear that Iris that that
definitely throws a wrench in your plans
oh yeah it's okay I mean I've always
been alone so I know I can do this but I
know I've been really financially
irresponsible and honestly I've never
sat down and thought about all the debt
that can accumulate within the years and
the interest and all the payments like
whenever I sat down and I wrote all
these down in paper that's when I am
like oh my God where is all my money
going yeah your money is making other
people Rich morning yes that's the best
reality check had to cancel on like
trips and like I was supposed to go on a
trip for Christmas and I had to cancel
that or in February I had another um
trip to go to Mexico for K I had to
cancel that and I'm just I just have to
say no to a lot of things but I know
that in the future it's going to be
worth it because I'm going to be free
and all all my hard work is going to pay
off absolutely aesome and we were going
to give you some uh resources Iris
number one is every dollar premium and
that's going to help you you said hey I
put this on paper I'm going to help you
put it digitally so you can carry it
around in the palm of your hand on your
phone make a plan and I'm also going to
give you a copy of our friend Ken
Coleman's book from paycheck to purpose
which is going to help you figure out
what that next step is for your career
Journey cuz I think that's what you need
you need something stable that you can
dig into for the next 20 30 40 years
that you love to do that you get paid
well to do as you build well so hang get
get her the get clear assessment too
boom we're hooking you up Iris use it
call us back let us know we can help in
any other way and we'll celebrate your
debt free scream when you get there this
is the ramsy
[Music]
show
this is the ramsy show our scripture of
the day comes from Proverbs
16:24 gracious words are a honeycomb
sweet to the soul and healing to the
bones Mark Twain once said never argue
with stupid people they will drag you
down to their level and then beat you
with experience one of my favorite
quotes John it reminds me every time I
jump into the YouTube comment section I
go this was a mistake should have
listened to Twain on that
one I think we'd all be a little better
off if we listen to Twain agreed in life
he was the original Tweeter I mean the
man just spoke in tweets but it's one of
those reminders that like we're not
doing anything new we're finding bigger
ways to blow holes in the ship and sink
it faster but human Nature's human
nature yeah and that was before he had
social media he would have been it would
been a dark time for Twain to be around
today no way he would he would have beat
the
cancellation let's get to the calls I
need some hope John let's see if Cooper
can provide that in Olympia Washington
Cooper what is going
on hey how's it going I appreciate you
taking the call absolutely what's going
on with you oh I just got a I've got a
hopefully a simple question you can
answer so I'm 21 years old and I'm
trying to figure out if uh I'm currently
rent running out a house I'm trying to
figure out if now is a good time to
start looking at purchasing my own home
or it' be better to increase my savings
and whether I invest the stuff I have
now to maybe further my down payment um
I'm kind of a little bit lost because I
got a new job and so I'm looking for
what's the next step okay give us a
little bit of uh your financial picture
do you have any
debt uh I'm debt free I uh I've got uh
roughly like 25,000 in my savings
account and then uh I've got a 31,000 in
a CD loan that'll be pulling out uh in
January and is that is 25 is that your
emergency
fund uh no that's that's savings that's
everything I've got in the bank okay so
do you have a separate emergency fund I
do not have a separate emergency fund
okay let's call that your emergency fund
is that about six months of expenses for
you
um no that's it's 25,000 and I spend
roughly uh let's see three grand a month
so little more so 18,000 okay so let's
call 20 your emergency fund and we're
not going to touch that that's not going
to be part of this home buying process
so outside of 20 you have the the other
five plus the
31 yep and then I uh I have uh 12 12,000
inside of a uh a rth a van a Vanguard
Roth IRA um that I started two years ago
but now that with my new job I have the
option to use a Roth as my deferred comp
and so I've just been putting all my uh
money into that rather than my Vanguard
Roth and I didn't know if that was
something that I should pull out and use
for that because I'm not so sure certain
how much 12 Grand over you know a long
period of time is going to help out I
mean it would turn into a whole lot if
you left it alone I definitely would not
unplug the growth and tap into that um I
know there are some people say Hey you
can dip into your Roth and take out the
contributions without penalty uh I
wouldn't do that in your shoes you're a
young guy you got plenty of time for
compound growth to do its thing I would
use future income and current savings
for this home purchase and you'll get
there and what's your
income uh yeah so it works a little
different um so right now I making like
roughly 89,000 but uh
I have step pay so over the next five
years I get a pretty significant uh
increase and by roughly year five I'm on
year one right now okay uh year five
roughly will be probably 115 awesome so
we're going to call it 90 for now how
much can you save making 90 with no debt
if you just focus on saving up for that
down payment how much could you save in
a
year uh I'm bringing home roughly about
2,000 into my savings each month so
24,000 okay and that's before over time
uh I could bump that numbers up with
overtime for sure awesome so if we take
your 36 we add 24 over the next year
that brings you to a total of 60 Grand
you have for a down
payment yeah so what is your home the
parameter that will help you with this
to figure out the math on it is you want
to have the mortgage payment be no more
than a quarter of your after tax income
on a 15E fixed and you can use our
mortgage calculator on our website to
start crunching the numbers and what
that does it helps you figure out what
kind of home budget should I be looking
for and what kind of down payment do I
need to accomplish that
goal I see okay um and then you know as
far as over this next um you know the
year that I'm going to be going to be
working saving up for that down payment
you know what what should I be doing
with my money because you know I'm
renting right now and so that that's a
little Annoying just because I know I'm
basically burning money and then I I
know that having my money just in
savings account is losing losing
valuable or like noer Cooper my money
right now is in a savings account is it
and you know how much sleep I lose zero
it's in a high yield savings account you
know who else is
George okay you got to un unbelieve this
narrative that renting is you're burning
money renting shows patience it shows
responsibility as you get your financial
house in order because you know what's
really burning money when you can't
afford the mortgage cuz it's 60% of your
take home pay cuz you bid off more than
you can chew before you ready and th
those are the calls we get on this show
the air conditioner goes out or the hot
water heater goes out or whatever
whatever so I will tell you what I did
as to how I got a huge down payment
saved and how we paid off our house
early we put the money in a high yield
savings account and I'll tell you at the
time it was a 2% interest rate on
savings accounts and my wife and I were
freaking out we were like we are making
money hand over fist with this and now
it's four 5% and so you can make somec
money just holding money in a savings
account don't invest it don't put it in
a CD locking your money away with
penalties if you take it out early just
put it in a high yield savings account
and be patient and sign the lease for
another year as you continue to rent and
save up more
money okay ideally I want you to put 20%
down I think for a young guy making
really good money who's debt free you
should be able to put 20% down avoid
that PMI private mortgage insurance and
keep that payment to no more than a
quarter of your take- home pay hey
Cooper are you the first guy in your
gang to make this kind of
money uh yeah yeah I am okay um what
about your
family um I would say uh my parents
are they definitely didn't start where I
was at okay you know they the retirement
age now and so maybe the last two years
they were okay getting roughly what I am
now so let's let's round up and say
you're making 100 Grand there's this
perception with people who don't have a
100 Grand that all of their problems
would be solved with 100 Grand and if
they had 100 Grand they could buy any
car they wanted any house they wanted
and what are you doing you make a
hundred grand you're renting you're
going to drive a used truck you idiot
you make a hundred
grand if you want to be a millionaire
you got to slow down and you have to
change you have to not take money advice
from broke people or from people who
don't know what they're talking about on
the
internet if you will rent for 12 months
and you will dump all this money after
you pay your debts off into a high yield
savings account and just be
patient this is just the slow pain of
getting in shape it's every day you're
going to wake up in a year and you will
have transformed your entire F uh uh
Financial
picture okay listen to anybody be slow
and boring dude slow and boring are you
in right now as
well yeah so um how much what
percent so initially I was so I started
work working in high school and I was
that's when I was putting all my money
into that Vanguard uh rth and then uh
you know from High School to essentially
this last February where I got this new
job I just basically been you know
working 80 hours a week trying to boost
my savings account as much as I can and
so I was putting all my money into that
Vanguard WTH but now that that I've got
my new job I'm just putting in$ 700 uh
dollars into my
457b okay I say that because it could if
you're really jonesing to get a house
you can pause investing for a short time
so that you have an extra 700 bucks to
put towards the savings
schol yeah if that's say short period of
time I'm talking a year time how long is
that yeah no longer than a year or two
if it's going to be longer than two
years to get this house I would continue
investing and you can split the
difference maybe you do 200 bucks or 300
bucks but if you're really jonesing for
a house which I would caution to have
patience and do it when you're ready um
that's an option to speed this process
up cuz you're already working your tail
off man you're crushing it I'm proud of
you you're doing the right things just
don't get distracted and be the tortoise
not the hair that puts this hour of the
ramsy show in the books my thanks to Dr
John deloney all the folks in the booth
keeping the lights on and the audio
going and you America thanks for
listening we'll be back before you know
it
[Music]
n